hello everyone and welcome to one of the
craziest games that happened yesterday
uh it's a game between daniel dubov and
yanni ponnishi
and even though nippon she is quite a
lot higher rated in classical chess
in rapid chess they are almost uh
identical
it's a number 12 for duba versus number
nine for ayani pogba
but they are not uh the highest rated uh
rapid russian players in the world as
there is also uh alexander grishock who
is the higher rate highest rated
uh currently number seven in the world
but still quite a clash
and uh the the game is just uh awesome
it has its ups and downs and it's uh
well
very unique as the two of them i think
are uh
probably the uh the most uh exciting
players uh
we we have nowadays uh so without
further ado let's check it out as
we we have quite a lot to enjoy in this
one so duba
with the white pieces opens with e4 now
we have c5 yangos for the sicilian
defense knight f3
d6 and d4 now we have captures captures
and now
knight to f6 knight to c3 and a6
uh yeah nipple goes for the knight of
sicilian
uh and here we often say that there are
many moves you can play here
bishop e3 bishop g5 bishop e2 bishop c
for a3a for
h3 h for g4 like anything goes here
okay maybe not g for right away but uh
f3 like and
you can play anything here but here we
have f4 so
again something that we haven't seen uh
quite often
uh so-called amsterdam variation uh and
uh nipple strikes in the center with e5
we have knight to b3 and now bishop to
e7 and
here that do both captures we have
captures captures and the queens come
off the board
we have queen captures bishop captures
and now
bishop the g5 and already very
interesting things
will happen uh there is one in the game
in the database where bishop to e3 was
played was played in 1977 european
championship between kronoslav hulk
and mirza pavlov that ended in a draw
but here after bishop to g5
uh it is as of move tender we have a
completely new game
so let's see how nipple deals with this
he goes knight b to d7
just continues development and now a4
uh preparing to grab more space on the
queen side with
h6 pushing back that bishop and here
not bishop to e3 like uh uh like
in the game we've mentioned but rather
bishop to h4 and now he's basically
uh offering a pawn because knight
captures an e4
is possible the bishop will be hanging
on h4 and this is exactly what nepo goes
for
knight captures on e4 and now bishop
captures on d8 so now if king captures
then knight captures knight
so here knight captures in c3 instead
and now
bishop to c7 just getting the bishop out
of harm's way and
black does the same knight d5 attacks
the bishop and bishop to d6 now
so what dubo got for his extra for his
pawn sacrifice is that the king will not
be castling for the moment and he still
has the bishop pair so let's see
if this is worth a pawn however knight
to e3 now
comes with the threat of knight captures
on c2 and also
maybe the bishop will be lost so here uh
dubois decides to give up yet another
pawn
to save the bishop and uh uh well
to prevent knight captures on c2 so he
plays bishop to d3
but now gives up the g2 pawn as well so
nepo just grabs it knight captures and
g2 with
check king to d2 and now knight to f4
and now
again the bishop is under attack and uh
there's uh well
really not all that much you can do here
if you try
uh well there's not much you can try
here you can just uh
waste a few more moves but that bishop
is coming over the board so
he will not be keeping the bishop pair
but it doesn't matter
rook ate the g1 not this rook the g1
rather this rook to g1 going after the
pawn because if g5 you want to have this
rook on h file to play h4
so the g7 pawn is under attack nipple
defends it
and now a5 just grabbing more space on
the queen side
and now nepo takes the bishop of the
board knight captures on d3
c captures on d3 and now okay here maybe
you could have captured with the king
but i think uh
i think double wanted to keep uh this
pawn on d3 to
not allow black some really really rapid
expansion here so the
uh pawn on d3 will prevent that even
though you usually don't want to mess up
your pawn structure
but okay here we have b6 and this is the
really amazing moment
because if you look at the position now
uh there aren't all that many moves
black can play
you cannot move the knight because this
pawn falls you can't play
something like f6 to defend the pawn
because the g pawn falls
uh the rooks cannot get into the game
you cannot castle you can't play rook b8
to push b5 so uh even though uh dubo is
down to pawns it it doesn't look like
nepo has all that many moves so here
we have b6 uh preparing to play bishop
to b7 and bring the rook to c8 this is
probably the the only thing black could
have done and uh
rook to c1 just grabbing hold of that c
c file
going for rook to c7 so nepo quickly
plays bishop to b7 attacks the rook on
h1
and now rook h the e1 and now uh well
you think you might think okay rook the
c8 and
we've you know taken care of all of our
problems rook the c8 actually loses on
the spot
uh it's um not at all clear why but i
will show it after rook captures with
check bishop captures
uh we're gonna play a captures on b6 now
create a beautiful past pawn here
and if the past pawn is captured then
comes bishop captures on e5
attacks the rook and now there's not
much uh there's not much to be done here
you are threatening some nasty
discoveries because the rook is aligned
with the king
so you might fix both of those threats
by castling now there's no discovery and
the rook is not under attack but
there is bishop to d6 and now the rook
is under attack the rule cannot go here
and if you play this then just bishop c7
and the white wins so a very very tricky
position no doubt uh dubo had this
in his uh preparations as this it's very
bold to play something like this against
nipple where he just sacrificed two
pawns
straight out of the opening but nepo
just plays bishop captures on a5 he just
grabs another pawn
so rook the c7 by dubaf and now bishop
to g2 you have to move the bishop
nepal moves it to g2 and now knight to
c5
attacking the knight so just capturing
the knight is the threat
so knight captures on c5 we have bishop
sorry knight captures bishop captures
and now f6 and it seems that nepo
took care of all of his problems but uh
one a very
big problem remains how to develop this
rook because the entire seventh rank is
covered and also what to do with this
rook so it's not
all that clear and uh duboff goes for
rook to c1 and now he wants to
double up rooks on the seventh rank uh
to or as we like to say promoted them
into pigs so here we have bishop to h3
this is a crucial defend uh defensive
idea as you have to cover that
c8 square so here rook the e7 with
check king to d8 and now rook to g7
so going after those pawns we have
rooked the c8
putting pressure on the bishop here and
now well you could play bishop to b6
check
king to e8 this does not result in
checkmate because that bishop on h3 is
guarding the rook that was the idea
behind bishop to h3
however here dubo finds another idea he
plays d4 and he sacrifices
yet another pawn now what's interesting
about this pawn
is that it most certainly cannot be
captured but it's not
immediately clear why however nipple
doesn't believe that and
that's exactly what he goes for here
probably you should play something like
g5 prevent
white from capturing it upon but nipple
boldly captures on d4
and now there's a problem uh bishop to
b6
check we have king to e8 and now okay we
don't have this because the
rook is defended but the e file opened
up and now there's
rook to e1 with check king f8 and now
rook to e7 and now we have two fully
operational picks here on the seventh
and it's it's looking extremely
extremely scary for black it's not at
all clear how
he will even continue playing this so
here
bishop the e6 a very creative move uh
saying that okay i'm not
going to allow you any checks here and
if you capture of course your rook falls
so rook the a7 getting this rook out of
harm's way
and now g5 just defending that pawn and
here
bishop captures on d4 so now uh only now
will do both start uh
collecting the pawns that he so happily
sacrificed and also it guards the b two
pawn
so it makes sense uh and here rook the
g8
trying to trying to trade off a pair of
rooks just rook g to e7
not allowing this trade uh we have
bishop to b3
now with some ideas of maybe rook to c
to check but just
rook e to b7 uh and now you don't really
have the option of delivering
some checks because there's a too much
of that back rank weakness black has to
worry about
so here it bishop back to e6 and now
rook captures an a6 again continuing to
collect pawns attacking the bishop
bishop to f7 and now even rook captures
on f7
going after that bishop here so rook to
g7 defending
and now rook captures an h6 so first
dubo sacrificed all of his pawns and now
he's recollecting them
with interest we have rooked the g6 as
the rook is now also under attack so
rook to g6
and now rook to h7 again attacking the
bishop and now
bishop to d5 attacking duval's rook here
but now the position is completely
winning for white so feel free to pause
the video and
win this game for duba while i give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting a most
forcing idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's uh bishop the g7
with check and now you can see that
there's nothing to be done
if the king moves rook to h8 is
checkmate if the king moves to the left
if king to d8 it's not a problem just to
rook h8 to check and after you give up
the bishop this is again
checkmate so obviously the king cannot
move your only option is to capture the
bishop but then after the
bishop is captured now you just
recapture here and
there is no no more uh point in playing
this as the two rooks will of course
completely dominated the
the rook and bishop and this is a
completely winning endgame however after
this bishop to d5 move
uh dubo was extremely low on time for
quite some time now and he's constantly
playing at that 10 seconds increment
and he didn't spot bishop g7 check he
played rook b to d7
and now the game continues for a little
bit
we have bishop the e6 check and now only
now dubo goes for bishop to g7 check but
now it's different because now
after king to e8 you don't have rook h8
check because the rook is now on d7
so there's no point in that so you have
to
waste the move playing rook to a7 but
now rook to d8 with
check king e3 and now rook to d7
again uh finding some safe squares for
the king so now
any check checks can be met with just
moving the king so here
8 check king to e7 and now even rook
captures on a5 so duba grabs another
pawn
and now he's simply up upon and uh if he
can
uh organize his pieces maybe those pawns
can be pushed to become queens so
bishop to f7 not allowing any
discoveries with this bishop
now bishop to e5 we rook to e6 putting
pressure on the bishop here
and rook to g7 do both now ready to
collect even more pawns and now rook to
b7
and here you have to be careful if you
capture on g5 then black captures on b2
the bishop on e5 is pinned
so of course dubo eliminates this threat
by playing king f2 now the bishop is no
longer pinned
and now rook to c6 we have bishop
to c3 and now rook back to h6
going after the h2 pawn king g3 duval
just defends it
and now rook to d7 with some ideas of
starting a
checking spree here we have rook to e5
with
check uh king to f8 attacking the rook
here and now
rook g captures on g5 so now dubo is
up two two pawns and nepo is without any
pawns
it's funny how things turn out like that
because nipple was
up for like four pawns maybe even five
at some point maybe it was four
but okay uh rook to d3 with check king
to f4 and now bishop to e6 and here
a nice uh mating idea as the rook cuts
off the king completely from the third
rank the bishop covers these squares and
now rook to h for check will be deadly
you're going to have to block and then
rook captures his game over so here
rook to e2 uh making some room uh
for his king on e5 and now rook to h4
with check king e5 and now rook to d5
again with
check king captures on e6 and now rook
captures on g5 and now
uh dubo uh failed to take advantage of
his great position and now it's nepo is
actually up material but okay it's still
bishop and two pawns for a rook so those
pawns could be very scary
we have bishop to f6 attacking both of
the rooks and now
rook to g6 spinning the bishop and now
king f5 doesn't work because you simply
play rook h to g4 and you save both of
the rooks so instead
we have rook to d2 now going for rook to
d8
checkmate so you have to prevent this
rook to e4 with
check here dubo goes back rook e back to
g4 by nepo dubo again threatens
checkmate rook to e for check
king goes back rook back to rook e back
to g for nipple happy with the draw
but the duboff says nope we're gonna
we're gonna play on because i still have
two past pawns
so uh he starts pushing h4 we have king
rook to g2
uh offering a trade of rooks we have
rook to d8 with
check king to f7 and now rook to d7 with
check
king e8 nepo just repeating moves sorry
i meant
to e8 and nepo just repeating moves and
now rook again to d8 with
check king to f7 rook d7 check king to
e8 attacking the rook and now rook the
b7 again dubois declines a three-fold
repetition
so rook to h6 now just getting the rook
out of harm's way now this rook can move
this
rope will no longer be hanging and you
cannot push h5
so here bishop to g5 attacking the rook
and now
rook to f2 check king g4 and now rook to
e6 saying uh
there's there's no way for you to make
progress here
uh but king h5 and now again uh
rook to f7 offering a rook trade we have
rooked the b8 to check
king to d7 and now rook to d8 with
check dubo has to make moves extremely
quickly because for the last 20 30 moves
he's been playing uh with uh
with some 30 seconds on the clock only
on increment so king c6 uh we have rook
to d
for now uh and here comes king to c5
chasing back the rook rook the a4 and
now
rook the b7 going after the b2 pawn so
here we have rook to a2 but now you can
already feel that
uh the white rook being so passive and
nothing really happening
it's uh most likely that white will not
be able to to do anything here so king
c4
king the g4 we have king to b3 now
chasing away the rook
rook a3 check king captures and rook to
a3 now offering a trade of rooks
with uh which nipple could accept but he
declines first with rook to be for check
king to h5 and only now he accepts it
rook captures an e3
bishop captures and king to c2 and it
was
in this position that the players agreed
to a draw as this is a very well known
uh drawn end game uh at some point
the pawn might continue uh being pushed
forward but the rook can always
sacrifice itself for for the pawn and
that's just it the
there is no way to win this for white so
there were
a lot of moments where duboff could have
could have
you know played better and gone for the
win but with so little time on the clock
and
it took him a lot of time to play you
know such tricky chess
but in the end nepo is i mean one of the
candidates
not just one of the candidates he's
currently leading the candidates
tournament with maxine marshall lagrave
and of course he's uh as you can imagine
very very strong and
dubo was unable to to grab a full point
here
uh but really really exciting game and
uh yeah
it's uh you know what what i was
expecting when i
saw uh the two of them were playing and
a lot of you have
suggested a game so i thought it was
fitting uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
here are the standings uh from the first
day uh as you can see magnus carlsen in
the lead with
four points so only lost that one game
to wesley so
uh wesley saw in yani publishing with
three and a half then with three we have
maxim barcelo grav anishigiri temura
uh then followed with two and a half
nakamura young sister of duda arunyan
and sam shankland then which do
uh gujarati alexander grishok and daniel
dubov
uh and then with one and a half point
dingley rune and matthias bluebaum and
in last place uh the elenier dominguez
who who lost that game to carlson we
we've seen yesterday uh but yeah still
early two more days
of the preliminaries and then we go into
the into the main event
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed this really really uh
brutal brutal stuff for giving away all
those points and then collecting them
with interest uh you know
very nicely done uh i would like to
thank brian shoefield
uh mitchell comments uh ragudara and
austin del rio for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the second day of this
wonderful event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day